so this video came in through our
regular website you can submit videos as
well if you don't have the live race fan
line app you can go to theof on comm and
in those ways to hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three there's also a ways to submit a
video on via Dropbox here we go
what's up Theo my name is Casey I'm a
fan on the podcast thanks for checking
in with us Casey and if you look on
YouTube this man have a picture of a dog
in the back and this looks like um it
could be a Yorkie or something but I
don't even know what a Yorkie is dude
more I just wanted to send a video kind
of get your thoughts kind of bounce
something off of you
I'm a rollerblader and I've been doing
that for about almost 20 years I do team
pro hey that's wild let's hear more bike
tricks and stuff grind rails I'm really
good he's really good at what roller I
mean yeah it's good I mean there's
definitely I saw a dude [__] I saw a
dude that went off this big embankment
one time on on rollerblades and landed
on some tram tracks on these tram tracks
in Atlanta and he had to have broken
both of his legs I was probably 80 yards
away but you could almost tell that both
of his legs were broken let's hear more
though you sound like a safer skater but
it's one of the few activities that
people outwardly will hate you for yeah
yeah I'm trying to think that's true
so I just wanted to get your advice your
thoughts what do you do if you love
doing something but everybody else kind
of hates it that's a good question man
what I do look I'll say this you never
know when it's gonna come back in style
right now we might all have feet
everybody's got regular feet six years
from now they're [__] hammering
wheels into our feet at birth so you may
be ahead of the curve man at that point
you'd be 26 years ahead of the curve do
you be the Michelangelo of walking at
that point because
you know wheeling would become the new
walking and you'd be taking us
everywhere so that you know you have
that so you might be ahead of the curve
you never know when you are ahead of the
curve man you know and also what about
this dude
I used to scrapbook I grew up
scrapbooking bruh you know I'm saying
you'll find me at Michael's son posted
up in the back cuz a Michaels great
place to meet bad [__] alright and to
do scrapbooking and I did it for years I
got a much scrapbooks at the house and
bra I couldn't tell anybody you know I
couldn't tell anybody I was freaking s
booking but now they have dudes on
Instagram with 3400 posts
you know what Instagram is man
scrapbooking that's all it is so I was
ahead of the curve dude I used to do it
the old way you know I was Nelson the
mailman you know what I'm saying I was
out there puttin in work and doing
things out there and a hundred degree
heat and Nelson still getting grimaced
letter to you thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip then you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this cuz this is
alarming